there's an old adage in sports you never
want to be the guy that follows the guy
you want to be the guy that followed the
guy who followed the guy right so the
organization just got rid of its founder
uh and its face and there really wasn't
another face because as you guys have
pointed out everybody else that is known
in the that that has done public work
has done it undercover so he is the only
known face of that organization who
would right now given the amount of heat
that that is taking right now on top of
the open invite they literally just
hiked up their skirts and said that the
feds were open for business we showed
all the leg we've got all the way to the
panty line who wants to walk in there
and say yeah I think I want to take that
I want to I want to take that Dutch door
action I want to get screwed on the way
and screwed on the way out and I'm gonna
I'm gonna take over for a guy that's a
legend to his base and then at the same
time yeah the the people that just hired
me opened up uh and invited the feds to
come in for an investigation I think
that is probably a pretty small list of
people